what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 16th of august
the joint is brought to you by you ready
draftkings [__] ding ding
get ready for the fight of the [__]
summer it's pacquiao versus ogas hits
las vegas this [__] saturday the 21st
draftking sports book america's top
rated sports book has a knockout offer
for you ready
grab a pen
draftkings is offering 100 to one odds
on a punch being landed at any point
during the fight you won
you won
unless the other guy just [__] drops
when he hits the canvas just pick a
fighter to win and draftking sportsbook
will give you a hundred to one odds with
a single punch are you hearing what i'm
saying bet one dollar on either fighter
when you punch lands during the fight
you get a hundred dollars and free
credits
draftkings will make you a contender use
promo code joey when you sign up to turn
a dollar into 100 and free credits when
you bet on either fighter the winner and
a punch has landed during the fight
it's that easy don't pull your punches
get in the ring with draftkings and
footballs upon us college and pro
place your bet and draftkings will give
you 200 dollars in credit for either
college or pro football and now if you
bet a dollar on the boxing match and
they land a punch you get a hundred
dollars do me a favor go to draftkings
right now
download the sportsbook app right now
and enter code joey j-o-e-y
here's a little couple rules you got to
be 21
new jersey indiana pennsylvania only
restrictions apply see
draftkings.com sportsbook for details
now if you got a grammy problem go get
help call 1-800 gambler
call [__] uh
better help call somebody who can help
you
if if you're in indiana call 1-809 with
it
but if you're straight and you're not
going to have any [__] problems with
this
download the draftking sportsbook app
and let's win some [__] getus this
weekend
the joint is also brought to you by
one of my favorites manscaped
this is what dak sheppard she needs him
and his [__] wife not taking showers
and those other filthy [__] hollywood
couples
can you imagine what their [__]
smells like and all that [__]
those [__] celebrities are filthy
listen manscape could [__] help them
with the special transmission houston we
have a problem it's the [__] pubes a
chief total weightlessness with manscape
blast your [__] pubes into another
[__] dimension and it all starts with
the lawnmower 4.0 listen i love manscape
i shave my nuts i shave around the
[__] pole of death
i haven't shaved my [__] yet because
it's not needed but if i was swinging on
that [__] corner my [__] would be
nice and shiny this razor has gone where
no man
has gone before both your balls and
uranus
their advanced skin safe technology
features a ceramic blade to reduce
[__] nicks and grooming accidents
plus the lawnmower 4.0 has 7 000 rpm
motor and a travel lock it's even
[__] waterproof the new lawnmower has
an led light that's brighter than the
[__] sun
the weed whacker is waterproof and uses
the same skin technology that you use on
your balls only on your face so do me a
[__] favor right now
go to dra
manscape.com slash joey again
that's
the manscape.com package 4.0 is now
[__] global you get anywhere africa
singapore
australia europe you cannot find a
better deal in this [__] galaxy
they're gonna give you 20
off they're having a mid-summer sale
plus free shipping at manscape.com
joey that's manscape.com
joey that's 20 off free shipping at
manscape.com
[Music]
joey your [__] spaceballs will
[__] thank you
now without further ado let's get this
party started
the joint is coming your way [__]
[Music]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 16th of august we're
officially halfway there and then some
that said you're like [__] some
schools have started
like in the midwest in the south
uh my daughter goes back to school i
think september [__] 13th or some
[__] but that's it this is the last week
at camp
and it's gonna be a hot hot [__]
summer after this it was a great week
last week i want to talk to you guys
about a few [__] things
on a beautiful monday morning i'm
feeling good i'm looking good i'm
smelling good let me tell you something
i always [__] smell good okay i might
have a little wang to me sometimes after
i lay somewhere or i go to a gym
but i was reading this week somewhere
about celebrities that don't bait their
[__] kids or
what the [__] is wrong with people i
want to know what
the [__]
is wrong with people
bathing
cleanliness is next to godliness
all right that's what i [__] heard
when i was a young [__] kid that
cleanliness is next to godliness how the
[__] are you not gonna take showers but
let me tell you something and i was
talking about this on the patreon
podcast
that's a big thing in hollywood for you
people who don't know and are sitting
around
that's a way to get attention
that's the reason matthew mcconaughey
does it there's a bunch of actors
that don't come into a set and you'll
smell them
eight minutes before they [__] get
there i dog i've been on two sets i'm
not gonna discuss it
you could smell the [__] onion in the
air
they get there
and
they think it's cool
because they stick out it's another way
of sticking out it's thinking
so you know it's like a [__] hip
thing for them trust me i learned about
it in boulder you don't know how many
[__] girls i did coke with and after
20 minutes you smell this weird odor in
the [__] air
and you're like what the [__] is that
smell and then you get close to them
and you smell their bodies and they'll
tell you that they don't use deodorant
because they don't want to [__] up the
[__] whatever system the ozone layer
listen i don't give a [__] about the
ozone layer as long if you're stinking
that's all that matters to me i'm not
worried about the [__] ozone layer
and neither should you
it's 2 000 million [__] miles away
i'm not a [__] scientist but i don't
think you the only way you could ruin
the ozone is with that stink from under
the armpits
that stink will ruin the [__] ozone
that that will [__] it up
completely that i don't understand any
of that [__] i don't like it you know
but that's big out in hollywood a lot of
you so you read it that these people
don't bathe their kids unless they're
[__] physically dirty are you [__]
kidding me have you ever smelled your
kid after school they
stink
my daughter stinks after [__] school
my daughter's eight and she had to start
using deodorant when she was [__] six
she had a little wang to it i'm like dog
you got to start wearing [__]
deodorant so she puts deodorant on twice
she takes two showers a day one before
school and one at the end of [__] the
night at 8 30 to get that chlorine and
kid's breath and [__] the stink off
how the [__] don't you bathe your kids
guys you know
listen
i'm going on a [__] year next week of
being here and i gotta be honest with
you you know you never know when you do
things you never know what to expect
when you move you never know
what to expect when you go to a new
restaurant you never [__] know you
know you go you try the experience out
you have something in your head
you have a preconceived notion in your
head of what you're gonna do i mean i
did when i came here you know when i
left hollywood last year i left
to move here so my daughter could go to
school
my expectations were gonna be the same i
was gonna come here give a little
breather wait for the clubs to open you
know and then go back to my [__] life
once i got here i realized
that i didn't like that life anymore i
mean i just did not like it at all
anymore you know mike and i were just
talking about miss pat
okay i want to congratulate miss pat on
her new show on bet
i'm very proud of her anybody knows miss
pat anything about her she's worked
really hard to get this show on here
that book that she put out was great
and the tv show i have not watched it
yet but mike says it's [__] great and
i heard it from my neighbor she asked me
if i knew miss pat i go yeah she goes oh
my god i watched the show it was great
i am very proud of miss pat
but i'm gonna tell you what i'm not
proud of
okay
miss pat
should have been and i'm not saying
nothing bad about bet i love bt i
watched hustle and flow the other night
bet put on some good [__] movies
during the week i got nothing against
bet bt is a good network you know
they're great to african americans they
give them a [__] whatever i know miss
pat for a long time
miss pat's a hell of a comic a hell of a
person with a hell of a [__] story
miss pat
belongs on abc
or nbc
and i know she can't curse she can't do
this
miss pat is such a star
she'll figure it the [__]
out
but this is what bothered me about the
new hollywood
they didn't respect acting for comics
they did not respect it they didn't give
it the light it deserved
the agents have found an easier way to
make money they found
low hanging tree which is called the
road
and what are you watching now what are
you seeing now you've seen all these
young comics getting covered eventually
one you know every week a new comic has
covert you know every week look at jimmy
florentine he was supposed to see four
[__] shows it started with limp
biscuit last week on friday at the stone
pony outside at the outdoor stage how
safe is that [__] safe as [__]
limp biscuit canceled last friday with a
half hour
half hour before the [__] show they
canceled jim florentine his brothers
they all drove down there they were
standing there and limp bits get [__]
canceled
leonard skinned
cancelled next week i don't know if they
canceled in jersey but they had to
cancel four [__] shows
he's still up in the air by leonid
skinner i guess saturday night last week
he was supposed to go watch somebody
down there again they got sick they
[__] canceled but they canceled in
the afternoon that's not bad driving
down atlantic city then you get pissed
off
and then he was supposed to go see
somebody last night and he called me
last night about 5 30 when i was taking
uh mercy to kick boxing to tell me or
the friday night to tell me
that [__] the show he was going to
friday night got cancelled because the
guitar player that's four [__] guitar
players caught it
now my friends went to see guns and
roses
and they noticed something i know for a
fact that guns and roses is doing a
bubble nobody's allowed backstage
no talking no hanging out they each go
their own way after the show they get in
their car and that's the car they drive
with that's the driver they drive with
he's not allowed to see nobody they're
not allowed to do nothing
i mean listen it works
but that ain't the road
it works but that ain't the road
when you go on the road it's to talk to
people
it's to embrace people people want to
take pictures with you people want to
see you people you know
if you got to walk around with a [__]
covert bubble on you that's not the road
for that you might as well stay at home
and that's why i'm doing what i'm doing
i have nothing against comics going out
right now but it's not a good [__]
time
so right now like i see miss pat doing
this show which she taped you know
before you know i i guess maybe six
months out i don't know how what the
taping schedule is maybe
it was four months out who the [__]
knows you know when you act
when you go to do a movie now like i
have to do this thing right in two weeks
i got to be there one day earlier just
to take a covet test and wait in my room
then you're not really allowed to mingle
too much
monday i do another once i get my test
back i go to wardrobe like i did for the
apple tv show i did
and that's all you do for the day
tuesday morning you get up again and you
[__] take a rapid covet test
and they let you on the set and i'm
shooting two episodes so i guarantee you
they're gonna test me before the second
episode i'm not angry i'm not mad i mean
it's it's part
of the [__] game
when you walk into a comedy club or a
musician walks into a theater or an
arena
they're not testing you they're not
really you know they don't really know
who's coming up to you or whatever in
other words it's not a good time to
[__] travel
if you're in a band right now right now
how many [__] oh
iron maiden
bruce dickerson's got it
you know it's just it's guys it's just
eventually like i said last week it's
gonna get you
all you could do is be prepared but at
the same time
what pisses me off about hollywood is
this is the time
to get all these hitter comics
bill burr
you know even though bill's got an
animated show on tv what about
bert and [__] tom how about a buddy
show on fox give them what they want who
gives a [__]
you give worthless people more money
than you'd give those two [__] comics
you give people how many [__] shows
has doc shepard [__] killed how many
[__] shows has that shepherd been on
that have been canceled and they keep
giving them [__] shows they keep
giving this [__] guy shows i got
nothing against that shepherd but he's
never said a funny [__] thing in his
life okay i'm a [__] stand-up comic i
know what it is to go up there when
[__] there's 20 people in the [__]
audience he is not a funny guy how many
[__] shows are they gonna give him
but you got miss pat on [__] bet in
the dungeon on channel 138 miss pat
belongs on 2 4
or eleven which is fox depending on your
area check your local [__] listings i
have no idea where the [__] they're at
so you're gonna put this [__] stiff
on again
to kill another [__] show and miss
pat sitting up there and be devil a
[__] way from everything she belongs
on nbc cbs ab abc that's the network she
belongs in fox
the same thing with bert the same thing
with tom the same thing give whitney
cummings and [__] uh christine
whatever what the [__] is theo doing you
know what the [__] are these people
doing so that makes you think as a
[__] consumer i sit here every
[__] night watching this [__] [__]
tv how many [__] times can cbs put
blue bloods on how many [__] times
how many [__] lawn all the [__]
shows you know and they're all [__]
reruns let's get one of these [__]
hitters
miss pat right now is covetville you
don't want to have your comics out what
did i tell you guys if i'm a manager i
call my client and go right now is not
the [__] time for you to be sailing
around with a [__] umbrella right now
what you should be doing is going to
your local comedy club developing your
[__] act
so it could be the best act it could be
when this [__] blows up
you're not up on stage talking about
hacky [__] and [__] covet like i'm
doing now you're talking about life
that's what i would be doing if i was
doing stand-up comedy right now i'd be
at [__] uncle vinnie's every night
doing a guest spot
doing a set [__] getting down
preparing for a year from now
so i could go right back into a [__]
special and boom the special comes out
and now you're prepared by the time all
this [__] listen this is going to be a
five-year [__] window
we have a five-year window until all
this disappears five
[__] years i saw this the other night
on 60 minutes or whatever the [__] one
of those [__] tv shows that you sit
there at night like i'm sitting there at
night waiting for [__] alonzo bowden
i'm sitting there waiting for tom rhodes
i'm sitting there waiting for somebody
who's [__] funny on television and
you keep giving me these [__] comedic
actors that don't know dick about dick
this is what my point is so whose fault
is this is it hollywood's fault is it
the [__] agent's fault it's all their
[__] faults then you wonder why i ran
out of there like my ass was on fire
right out of there they didn't respect
the game no more they weren't they don't
respect the game no more they don't
respect the ability of comics anymore
you know louis ck did a great [__]
job for comics going up there writing he
would edit his own show he would cut it
he would cast it just to show you what a
comic could [__] do the strength of a
[__] comic is so strong
there is nothing we can't [__] do
right act [__] you know punch it up
till it could be really [__] funny
you give us time and we'll do it just
like roseanne did it just like tim allen
did it just like you know but they don't
want to do that no more these agents
don't want to do that no more and the
clients don't want to do it every time
the agent says let's take it to netflix
[__] netflix
[__] netflix we need this on abc we need
a [__] network behind this we need
this on nbc we need that 30 [__]
years of knowledge behind this
why is [__] russell peters in [__]
liberty city ohio
what he can't put on a [__] you know
this is what i'm saying guys
they don't give a [__]
these agents have gone rogue they don't
give send them out let them get cold you
know and listen if you throw enough
spaghetti on the wall
eventually one's gonna stick
trust me what i'm telling you wait till
the first comment goes out of [__]
control and ends up in the [__] icu
let's see what these [__] agents are
gonna do then what the [__] are they
gonna do that
i'm telling you this whole thing is
crumbling
i you know mike and me are bt
why
was that that why
because that's the let so these agents
never even called to miss pat and said
look
this is a [__] this is a hit here
this is a [__] hit here and i hope
that she does like two seasons on bt
and i hope that maybe they moved the
show you know for a lot of people who
don't know
bill maher started on comedy central
[__]
30 years ago
politically incorrect was on comedy
central when i got into comedy
central
then after a few years
he sold it to abc
and abc it grew with abc
that's the evolution of a real [__]
comic
but think about it shouldn't there be
more [__] comics on tv
bert had a great show with the [__]
one i did when we ate the emu
and all that [__] it was you know kind
of reality it was a great show
have you seen it again netflix is
[__] like you know
what about duncan charleston's [__]
show midnight whatever what happened to
that
they still haven't given them a [__]
answer that's what happened
gabriel's show they canceled on netflix
they weren't getting enough people go
[__] yourself netflix doesn't tell you
the [__] numbers they refuse to tell
you they'll tell you you did good
but they won't give you the exact
[__] number i need a number
i need a [__] number but all those
sitcoms on netflix
they don't [__] work i don't know
what happened to narcos
you know cobra kai comes back in [__]
december where'd you go to japan this
you cobra [__] kai where'd you
[__] go a [__] year and a half to
[__] do this [__]
so they started on youtube yeah they
started on youtube [__] red
so you have to
and they got two great comics on there
they have brett ernst and they have the
other guy that i did uh
the meatball king with that was a show
on disney that was a show on disney a
kids show i did the meatball king i
played the criminal the meatball king
and they had a falafel guy on there he's
a nice little arab guy he's on cobra car
he's better he works with brother and
said the dealership but that's why
listen they don't have the respect for
comics they used to have they just don't
oh yeah yeah we'll we'll get you a tv
show we'll do this we'll do that next
thing you know you're in [__] grand
rapids michigan
sitting in a room staring at a picture
of robin williams thinking to myself am
i next
and my next should i [__] hang myself
i mean i'm in grand rapids next this
week next week i gotta go to iowa city
the week after that i go to [__]
boise my career is on a [__] roll
[__] you
let's put something together let's get
us that's what i would tell my clients
right now listen there's no [__] road
it's just too unsafe
i don't want you getting in the head
with a [__] bottle i don't there's a
dog i hear thousands of stories
the planes ain't running right you know
luggage ain't getting there why would
you want to do this [__] it's like you
[__] momos that are going on vacation
i hope you [__] crash your [__]
plane into a mountain you stupid
[__] how stupid can you [__]
be
going on vacation paying extra [__]
money for what
for a hotel room that you're gonna you
know what the [__] is wrong with people
mind your [__] business go to a
cookout outside
you know i'm the king of cookouts
outside i don't even want to go inside
when i pee i go to my car and pee in my
little surgery bottle i don't want to go
to your [__] bathroom if i got a [__]
i come all the way home i don't give a
[__]
i'll give a [__] but you [__] morons
going on vacation 10 days what do you
think happens if you get [__] covered
while you're on vacation you got to sit
in that [__] room and pay an extra
[__] eight day wait till the hotel's
gonna pick it up because you i got
kelvin who gives a [__]
it's 300 a night [__] it used to
be 129 a night and now it's 300 a night
and you're gonna pay those five nights
until you [__] get cured or whatever
the [__] happens until you gotta stay
how many how many [__] things are
gonna stick in your nose i had to take
another [__] test tuesday this week
so i'm
i'm over it but i have an answer
and these networks listen tell these
[__] guys
tom bro all their tours aren't going to
start till september all these big tours
some of them are starting uh next week
some of them start this week the 15th to
16th
you know they're putting mandates you
want me to go on stage
and crack joke for a bunch of people
mask on
how shitty
is the show gonna be
if you gotta wear a [__] mask and go
to that show and sit there
i can't [__] relax
i'm gonna go to see your [__] guns
and roses with a mask on
you better you better check yourself
before you wreck yourself that's not
going to [__] happen
i think the mass mandate starts
september 13th in new york so that means
you got to go inside and sit with a you
can't even go to a gym without a [__]
covert path i mean a [__] gym
i need i gotta show proof of [__]
whatever to go to a [__] gym now
i don't know where this is going i have
no [__] idea you know
me i'm playing it by ear i'm gonna play
it close to my chest you know i'm gonna
i gotta drive in a few weeks to [__]
shoot this tv show i'm not
listen i'm not too happy about it
but i have to do it i have to work
and that's the the easiest thing i could
do to not get sick
and not get my family sick it's all on
the up and up
that testing you know how much a [__]
covert adds to a tv show
dollars
think about that
every show that gets made now on tv
add an extra four hundred thousand
dollars now
listen
you know when you shoot a tv show when i
shoot a tv show when i first got to la
there was money to be made you can make
great money shooting a tv show
especially after like season three
season four you get [__] paid
let's not [__] each other
the money that they're gonna spend in
coving is gonna come out of somebody's
pocket it's not gonna come out of these
dirty producers [__] pockets those
[__]
they'll let you die before they give you
money out of that [__] pocket trust
me
i have to next week
i have to sit on my computer for a
[__] hour one day next week
and go through my sag residuals and see
who the [__] ain't sending me residuals
and file complaints against them you
know how many times i got to do that a
year
twice a year
and when you realize what they're
stealing from you it's like really
why would you steal this
but you have to think about if they
steal it from everybody on the set
that's where the money is at
a couple like a year ago uh
a guy contacted me
and he's like hey man my show our show
the one you did with me
got put on netflix
you know if you could blow it up for me
and i was like listen i ain't doing [__]
for you
and he's like what are you talking about
pal i'm your biggest fan i go
you never pay me residuals all those
years
i shot those shows in like 2 000 [__]
four and five
those shows ran for [__] years
then they rebooted it and put them back
on [__] mtv and then they rebooted it
and put them back on netflix you know
how much money i've gotten from them
zelch okay
zelch not a [__] dime i've gotten
from them this [__] guy calls me up
he's like you gotta [__] retweet it
for me
please do me the favor are you i said i
ain't doing [__] you got to pay me
something
give me five grand give me two grand you
know i did six [__] episodes seven
episodes of your show
and you're not going to give me a
[__] residual but that's what they're
about guys
i don't ever want you to think that oh
you go to hollywood you're on the up and
up are you [__] crazy
i was telling somebody a while ago
when i was working on tv and films a lot
more and stand up was like maybe
40 of my income this is back 2007
2005 stand-up was a very small
percentage of my income
it was basically movies and tv shows
do you know
how many [__] people i had to
threaten on the phone
do you know how many times i had a call
and say what the where the [__] is my
check
tv and film
is 10 days
after you shoot a tv show or a movie
the production sends your agent a show
after 10 days guess what your agent does
he keeps the check
for 30 to 60 days
before he mails it to you
i don't play that [__] when you go on a
set for all you young comics and young
actors
when you go on a set
when they give you paperwork
the last sheet look at it and read the
fine print
it'll tell you
do this sign this here if you don't want
your check to get the agent your agent
to get your check
i would always [__] sign it and they
wouldn't get [__] they would call me a
week later and go hey man
we just realized you didn't sign the
paperwork we're not getting your check
why do you need my check
the job was six hundred dollars
you get 10 right i'll drop off 60
[__] dollars in the mail well that's
not right
why would you want my check you want my
check
because you want to bank it
and then get interest on my money even
if it's for the three weeks even if it
is 600
you know what
600 may not be nothing to him
but it's a big [__] deal to me when i
got to buy cat food and i got to make my
car payment and i got to buy groceries
do you understand where i'm going with
this
so on commercials
it's [__] 30 days
so if you shoot a commercial july the
4th
you won't get a check
until mid-august
and that's if you're on top of that
[__] check
like if you call your agent go hey i
talked to the production company
last monday the check is going on
wednesday you should get it on friday
i'll pick it up monday the [__] heads
will blow up they're like what are you
talking that's what i would do i would
always beat them to the punch
so as soon as i shot something
as soon as i'd signed the paperwork and
before i leave when they'd signed me out
i'd ask the production company
when do we get paid and they'll tell you
well it's going through
this corporation it's going through they
have like different payment companies i
forget what they're called now
they slip my mind
uh there's like three big ones i forget
what the [__] they were all your
paperwork's always already there your
w-2 is already there they just use one
of the three [__] people so i became
doug you know me
when it comes to money you know how they
tell you with covert follow the science
well
[__] you follow the money jack you know
right now i don't know if you you guys
saw what the makers of those vaccines
made
in the [__] hundreds of billions of
dollars
so while you're following the science
into the pocket of [__] modernist
pocket and johnson and johnson all these
people
you got to follow your money
when you do [__] anything listen
anything in life you got to follow your
[__] money last night i was talking
to my brother two nights ago
you know the framer george i love him
with all my heart some guy was supposed
to give him a check when he called the
guy his friend had the [__] check and
he hangs out at this bar then it looks
like you're going to the [__] bar to
get your money
i don't give a [__] to be there well he
he doesn't have to check his friend has
my check well let's go get the one
friend
to take you to the other friend and
he'll [__] get your money remember
goodfellas when they take the guy to the
lions they pick him up and take me to
your friend
take me to your [__] friend that's it
i'm not [__] playing games
why do you think i thought listen
the guy that represents me now in new
york the agent great guy
i love dave with all my heart
gay guy love him to death uh we were
friends we're always friends we talked
once a week
he called me this week to say i got no
luck with you you're not i had an
audition in an alley this week but i
couldn't get one in new york and i'm not
going they kept calling me when are you
putting the tape together what are you
putting it up listen and then my agent
had the balls to call me and go there's
another movie and they're working the
dominican republic that's what i want to
do is go to a third world [__] nation
right now you know you look at cuba you
know what's going on in cuba right now
cuba had it together last year when we
talked about cuba on coven they had it
together they had like 37 [__] cases
but what happened in cuba was they got
greedy they
they shut down tourism for a while
and after covert last year they had to
open it back up and what do you think
went down there those [__] canadians
and those germans and the italians
anybody who visits cuba brought covert
now now kovit's completely out of
[__] control in cuba they're using
hotels as makeshift hospitals outside
havana that's what's happening dominican
republic i have nothing against the
dominican republic i love that place i
love dominicans great [__] people
nothing but i just don't want to go to
dominican republic to shoot a [__]
movie right now that's just not gonna
[__] happen
none of that shit's gonna happen i'm
avoiding a [__] plane with all my
heart let me put it this way my wife was
supposed to go to tennessee with mercy
they cabashed it because not only are
you getting hit with covid now in the
midwest and in the south there's also
that other thing going that's rpv
it's like a kid's [__]
uh pulmonary [__] thing rpv apv i
don't know what the [__] it is
so what's going on with this is kids
were inside all winter
kids were inside
they didn't get a chance to build their
immune systems this apv [__] whatever
the [__] it is anybody correct me rpv
whatever this little disease is it's a a
lung disease just like [__] covet
it's a smaller [__]
disease
that kids get in the winter which they
shouldn't get in the summer but it's
spreading [__] rampant
so what i think is going on is
people
are going to the hospital to test for
did not test them for rpv
that test them for covert and they're
coming up [__] positive all these
kids all of a sudden now they're saying
kids are in hospitals and florida and
[__] texas and [__] it's not covered
hpv whatever the [__] it is yeah
so you got to worry about that now with
your kid so
planes and [__] is out for a while it's
over i don't need to be on a [__]
plane there's nobody i want to see
there's no way i want to do whatever i
need to eat i could eat here and i'm
good to go and that you know this is
what
kills me right now with comedy
and music you know right now i don't
know what the eagles are going to do
next week with the garden i think the
eagles are supposed to start a [__]
door
all these people you know unless you do
this
in a bubble like guns
and it's got to be like a short little
like if i was to tour right now
i wouldn't do october november
i would probably do
maybe january february
and just compact it do eight weeks and
that's the tour go to eight places you
want to go to for the year and that's
your [__] tour
if you get covered you get covered if
you don't get covered well then you
[__]
you know you could go home and suck your
own dick i don't [__] know what to
tell you but
my point of this whole thing was that
this is the time to develop a [__]
show
like right now i love to be talking to
hbo to develop a show about my mother
i'd love to be talking to showtime
anybody for me because i'm a [__]
mutt
but tom
burt
i could name allie wong
i can name 10 comics right now that
would destroy our network tv
one episode a week just like roseanne
just like tim allen and i'm not [__]
speaking out of line here
nobody is falling into that [__]
pipeline anymore there is nobody in that
pipeline yeah sebastian's got a cooking
show miss pat's on bet
i'm talking about the four main [__]
stations
why the [__] isn't one of us on there
not me
forget about me i'm 58 years old i'm
dirty i'm a [__] bum i get it but i'm
talking about
you know i'm really happy for
uh sam jay
her show on hbo is [__] tremendous
i'm happy for her
you know hbo is a great place for comics
they've always been very comic friendly
you know i love hbo
but it's time for network television to
figure it the [__] out
we've got too many people at home and
too many [__] comics that are
tremendous
you know and i still remember what
roseanne said roseanne
roseanne was basically the first person
to ever make me feel
special for being a comic roseanne was
on larry king live
i know she's got a couple interviews on
there that are [__] whack
but for every interview that she's got
on there that's whack i mean she's got
an interview on there that she talks
about oprah going into her brain
and stealing her ideas and [__] with
like
whatever roseanne is roseanne that's the
reason i love her
roseanne said something on there that
was tremendous
larry king asked roseanne
why
she didn't let the abc brass
into her christmas party roseanne
was no [__] joke
roseanne
i admire roseanne barr a lot not for
what she did
four years ago when she went on a tirade
and stuff listen
roseanne's always been crazy but i look
up to her as a comic
a big time comic and i'll tell you why
because roseanne barr said something
he asked her why didn't you allow
the abc brass into your [__]
christmas party and she said
that she was sick and tired of that
[__] that at the end of the day
they didn't know dick
that they wanted her their plan when
they got roseanne on the air
was to knock cosby off the air even
cosby
while he was raping [__] he was a
comic
and they were [__] nurturing him on
thursday nights over there
and he was doing whatever the [__] he
was doing i forgot all about cosby
there's another guy a comic you know so
nobody's in that pipeline guys
they're not putting anybody to develop a
[__] show and then they don't pick it
up
you know even with me they came to me
one day we love the pilot we love the
pilot oh we're gonna go with something
else it was me chris spencer a bunch of
us got deals at fox
nobody got it somebody else two other
shows got picked up that never went
anywhere
they don't know what the [__] they're
doing
and roseanne said it she goes listen
when you're a comic
you learn how to do everything
you learn how to greet
you direct
you write you coordinate
you do it all
even me towards the end here when i quit
i was still doing everything on my own i
was still getting my plane ticket i
don't let nobody get my plane tickets
i get my own plane tickets you've never
seen
listen
i think i took
three jokes from people over the years
that came to me and said hey
here's a joke for you
i wrote everything else that's why the
[__] sucked because
because i wrote it that's why it sucked
you know i was never known for my
[__] high level of material
but i wrote it myself
i took one joke from somebody somebody
actually said used his tag and it was a
stolen [__] tag i ended up getting
into 18 fights i had a spit in the guy's
face
you know it's not what i do so i said
that's it i'll never take nobody else's
material but
we write
we plan
you have to look at your notebook and
decide well i
i already got three [__] there i can't
say another [__] here i gotta put the
[__] there and when you think about it
that's how [__]
tedious it really is
you have to go into your script that
hard and go okay i already said that bit
there i'm already talking about [__]
here
i'm already talking about lighting this
guy on fire here i can't keep mentioning
it you know there's all these things
that go into when you watch bill burr's
[__]
you know
paper tiger that's as brilliant as it
[__] gets
why bill burr i mean i'll tell you why
bill burr is on tv because he told them
to go [__] themselves a long time ago
too you know he did the animation thing
because it just basically works for him
but any real [__] comic
doesn't want to be on tv
and i'll tell you why because of the
[__] rules
the rules are brutal
you know a network will send you [__]
constantly you know you don't see
chappelle doing tv no more after that
beat me thinking comedy central you know
you just don't see it
yeah
they
they turn you up you know what i'm
saying like they [__]
turn you the [__] on
and then
that you know you get burnt out on them
if they just leave you to [__] alone
they didn't bother the team with tina
fey all those years
and they didn't bother [__] tracy
morgan on there all those years and i
don't know if you have an idea what
comes out of tracy's mouth
tracy is [__] out of his mind
but they did it the right way or nbc
nobody [__] bothered them
if you established that from the
beginning
as a comic if you go in there
and on your third episode you tell the
people like listen i don't give a [__]
this is what i'm doing
they'll follow a suit with you i don't
know if a lot of you people know this i
don't know if i'm allowed to tell the
story i read it
i don't know if i'm allowed to say it
but i'm going to say it anyway
they told david chase in episode seven
of the sopranos
that they didn't want to see tony
killing somebody
they explained to david chase
over and over again that hbo didn't like
the idea of a crime boss
killing somebody that in real life
minions would do that for you know like
lower guys on the totem pole would do
that
david chase disagreed and put the
episode out as is of tony choking the
[__] rat
hbo almost canceled the series
hbo almost canceled the [__] show
over
tony choking the [__] guy
but
when you're an artist
you do what you think is right
you're not an artist you're a network
you went to college
and then came out and became this with a
college degree
it's not that you did a show for [__]
30 years you don't know what the [__]
you're doing
and that's what happened with chappelle
think about if you've been doing comedy
for 20 years
and some [__]
stupid white kid comes up to you that's
24 and it's telling you how to write
your show you're not going to go for it
either eventually you're going to tell
them to go [__] yourself and that's the
standoff
that's network and that she was a comic
and a human being when you became a
comic
you already were given the finger to
society
so why are you playing this [__] game
with these people because they're
[__] paying you the weekend club's
gonna pay you too you say whatever the
[__] you want you do whatever you want
and if you want to get your dick sucked
in the green room you can you know you
do what the [__] you want i'm not saying
get your dick sucks in the green proof
you know get it get your dick sick in
the car the green rooms usually have
cameras now they're a bunch of [__]
perverts but what i'm trying to say to
you is that
if you stick up for yourself and
tell them exactly how the [__] you feel
and then at the end tag it listen if
this doesn't work for you then we'll
wrap it up no no no no they've got money
tied up in you
they've got money invested in you
you know for years i would call clubs
like my agent would call me and go
you're going to
buffalo this week
who are you bringing as a feature
and i would tell them dean delray
k quigley george perez you know what the
club should say to me
oh we already have a feature act
do you mind coming by yourself and i
would go no
here's what you're going to do
we'll cancel the week
and call me when you don't have a
feature
that's your deal
so either i come in this week with who i
want to
or
i'll come in in six months with my
feature
well it's too late i don't give a [__]
i don't give a [__] i'm not in business
here to book the road for you
i'm bringing somebody with me that's
what headliners do
and that's what i'm doing whether you
[__] like it or not
and they would go okay
when i would negotiate for money i would
say this is what i want
and they would say well they can't give
you that well
call me when you can give it to me
until then we'll just part friends
let's see what we could do yeah let's
see we could [__] do that's the
mentality you gotta tell them to [__]
off like i'm not doing it
i'm not doing it get somebody else to
[__] do it oh you have 300 tickets
sold oh well then you're gonna have to
do it
i don't give a [__] what you're thinking
it's not important what you're thinking
it's what i'm thinking that's [__]
important not what you're thinking i
don't give a [__] what you're thinking
you bought a comedy club you didn't have
the patience to do what we do
you didn't want to [__] put the work
in now you want to come in here and tell
us how to run our show
take a [__] hike my friend
take a [__] hike
go talk to somebody who doesn't know
better
speaking of knowing better
i want to talk to you guys about
something
i know you guys have been uh watching me
for the last whatever
i know i've had some problems on the
show you know when i first started i had
some focus problems i had to
do things you know
i was [__] up is what i'm trying to
say to you you know what i'm saying like
before the knee surgery after the knee
surgery i was a little [__] up
in the head i'll never forget that one
day
i was downstairs here on the computer
and somebody rang the doorbell like a
neighbor of mine and i was
so out of it like not on drugs or high
or anything i mean i was just i'm like
i'm not answering the [__] door i'm
just not [__] doing it you know
i remember when i was in the halfway
house
you know i'm talking about the halfway
house because this it was a [__]
rough weekend this weekend it wasn't a
rough weekend
sunday was my 33rd
or 34th anniversary that i got sentenced
in prison it was august 15
1988 so it just i was talking to the you
know we we did the chapter this week on
the kidnapping and that's the chapter
that we're focusing on this week and all
the [__]
and i was thinking about when i got in
the [__] halfway house and i got into
uh when you first get to the halfway
house you go to a seven-man room
but after you're there for a while and
you get some [__] points they put you
in a three-man room
and that's not bad the only thing that
sucks about the three-man room is that
there's a bunk bed
and then there's a bed
so
the guy who had the bed looked just like
jim norton just not jim norton ed norton
from the honeymooners are carney he was
his [__] twin this guy we in fact we
used to call him norton everything he'd
say stop calling me that i don't look
like norton who gives a [__]
when i moved to a three-man room
it was norton in the single bed
my main man alejandro ray and the bottom
bunk and they put me on the top bunk i
wasn't 400 pounds and i was in shape
then
and i used to have to climb the bunk bed
and you know go to the bathroom and
climb down
and it kind of sucked so one day i went
to alex i go alex listen this is what
we're gonna do we're gonna get rid of
[__] norton
he's like how are you gonna get rid of
him i go we're gonna torture him
till he taps out you know [__] in his
shoes
crazy glue on the phone anything we
could do we glued his [__] hat
to the couch i mean we if you could do
it
we could do it it was a slow torture he
was a sweetheart of a guy we didn't let
him know we were torturing him it was
just like things would happen you know
his car would be a flat tire we just did
different things to him he was way older
than us you know he was like my age now
i feel guilty telling you guys the story
because he was the sweetheart of a guy
but i was sick and tired of going to
that top bunk
okay if it's between the top bunk and
you
i i got and i went to him like a man i
go listen do you mind sleeping on the
top bunk
me and alex like to talk at night he's
like no nobody's getting that single bed
all right
so i'm like how can i get rid of this
[__] guy this went on for two months
we were torturing them we hid one of the
sneakers we
you know we hit his forks
anything we could do this guy to make
him like [__]
think about his life
so
i used to work in westminster uh
colorado at the time westminster's next
to 104th and thornton
and there used to be a mall and i used
to go to the movies and there was a
magic
shop at the mall you know you go on them
by magic tricks and [__] fake eyes
and
and all this [__]
they also had those things you put in
cigarettes and when they light it up the
cigarette blows up
so i was doing it to people you know i
was doing it to a couple people
i was working this [__] cigarette
thing for about three weeks
and one day i'm sitting in the car and
i'm like [__] maybe i should do this to
norton
maybe this will be the [__] deciding
factor
so i get home on a friday night all the
invics are waiting for me i'm bringing
in like a [__] ounce of coke
i'm slinging coke from my hotel room oh
this is crazy
[__] bctc was crazy there was a chick
patrice twining she was sucking dick on
the first floor
you wouldn't even have to go into her
apartment she would just open the door
and you just stand in the hallway like
holding on to her door and she would get
on her knees to suck your dick and the
counselors were going how you doing hey
how you doing they didn't know you were
getting your dick she's like can they
see me no you're inside the [__] door
they can't see you we weren't allowed
into the girls apartments but we could
talk to them in the hallway
so you know well after all that shit's
done i get my dick sucked i go upstairs
and i see that norton left the
cigarettes on the [__] counter dog
i [__] stuffed all those [__]
cigarettes
what i mean i stuffed them i got a
toothpick
and i [__] stuffed them in deep so if
the first one if you smoked over the
first one the second one would get you
and then if you continue to smoke the
cigarette there was also one in the back
to really knock you the [__] out i
put all his [__] i put all the plugs
in there i had it all perfectly
and
i [__]
went to bed we all went to bed norton
came in last it was dark out
so we're in the bedroom and we're making
little [__] stupid [__] noises we're
going like huh
we're making all these noises
and norton's like we had a pillow on his
head he's like well you guys shut the
[__] up and we're giggling we're still
making noises and [__]
and finally
eureka this [__] gets up all
confused he throws the pillow on the
floor and he goes on to the living room
the beauty was he didn't turn on the
light
he just sat down at the coffee thing me
and alex held our breath we're like
let's see what's going to happen
and sure enough
you hear a cigarette getting pulled out
of the [__] marlborough box
you know i'm just assuming he puts in
his lips and i go alex
with five seconds from d-day
and all of a sudden you actually heard
the light of go ch
and you see him go back
there was like a little shadow on the
wall
and there was nothing but darkness
and all of a sudden
you just saw did you guys see the movie
heat when de niro shoots [__]
the guy at the end of the mexican dude
trejo he shoots him at the end they
don't show you him shooting de niro's
shooting trail
they show you the house from outside and
you just see the sparks
going up you don't see any bullets you
don't see any bodies you don't see any
guns
that's all we saw from the bunk bed
was a shot of like lightning pow
and then it went by and i'm like oh [__]
and i stuffed him so much i thought his
head had blown off his [__] shoulders
when he lit that cigarette
we waited like five minutes
and i go alex let's go check he hasn't
said a word he didn't say anything for
five minutes
we tiptoed out there
and we [__] just saw him he was just
sitting in his chair
with the cigarette in his mouth he was
blown apart there was nicotine all over
his shirt and he's just sitting there
going like this
that's how i felt when i got here and if
that's how you feel right now
better help is for you
better help is an online counseling they
connect you
with the perfect therapist for me it was
dana i love it
okay you can meet with them once a week
twice a week you can email them on the
site
they do the
meeting with you
on the website you could do it on the
phone through the website or on zoom
it's cheap and guess what it works i am
not a therapy type of guy but on this
last [__] situation i had to swallow
my pride and go for it i would never
even talk about going to therapy i went
to therapy when i was in the halfway
house and i did not like it i did not
believe in it and i got to tell you
after i moved here i was having problems
i spoke to erica she told me that she
had gone to see an online therapist at
first i was skeptical and i got to be
honest you better help
knocked it out of the park i'm way
better right now
because they taught me different things
they taught me how to cope with
different situations how to read my
triggers
how to see when things are gonna go awry
and i'll tell you what i'm a better man
i feel a lot better i'm sleeping a lot
better and yes for years i always said
go to your friends
well all my friends were [__] comics
so they were one jaded when they would
give me the advice
that i needed
i went to betterhelp and dana knocked it
out they will connect you
with the right therapist
let's read what they have here
better help is therapy for the 21st
century
again this is not a crisis line this is
not self-help
better help is professional therapy
online
listen i am the most hard-headed person
in the world i hate all that stuff and i
welcome this when i have a call like the
first three times i would call her like
we would have a meeting i would get
anxiety and i told her about it and she
goes i'm happy you told me about it this
is what you need to do
and i wrote everything down dane is
great they have a flexible schedule you
could do phone or video calls at your
convenience
you get a good match they'll put you
with a licensed therapist who's right
for you and they did for me with dana
one shot they did i told them what my
problems were and they took care of them
it's fast and when you sign up you can
start talking to your therapist in less
than 48 hours
no waiting around it's affordable and
you don't have to be a fancy ass new
yorker to pay for this and financial aid
is available so do me a favor just for
the listeners
of this podcast betterhelp has a great
offer to help you get started you ready
visit betterhelp.com
right now help help
calm
putting code diaz
slash diaz and we're going to give you
10 off your first month
betterhelp.com
diaz and
on top of talking to you can send the
messages anytime they'll get back to you
within
sessions and if you want to switch
therapists you can do it anytime for
free betterhelp.com
diaz
for 10 off your first month
back to the situation at hand now sorry
about the glasses i lost the other good
ones i lost two good pair of good
reading glasses i'm down to this one and
another pair of reading glasses and i
got my prescription glasses somewhere
around here but the [__] arm broke
you know how that goes i don't have to
listen they give you a little [__]
screw like this if i got reading glasses
and the reading glass breaks how can i
put that little [__] tiny screw in
the [__] thing so you know you can't
[__] the one in this life and nobody can
help you my wife has to [__] put
glasses on too so my prescription
glasses are sitting there with a leg
[__] broken it looks like a [__]
tripod
it's like i was telling you before
better life
better help better life what the [__] am
i thinking like i was telling you before
better help
it was kind of rough this weekend not
written that wasn't what rough at all i
just
when it comes to that prison [__]
i keep it close to me
and i'll tell you why keep it close to
me in case i decide
to think i could slip
i keep that prison
and that thought caught close to me i
thought i was invincible when i was 25
years old
and that kidnapping and that thing
made me
believe i wasn't invincible
and that i was vulnerable and that i was
a [__] idiot for doing what i did and
i would never do it again
i'm very happy
about my prison experience i didn't get
raped i didn't get [__] in the ass
none of that [__] i didn't [__] nobody
in the ass
i got into one misunderstanding
but that whole thing taught me patience
it taught me the patience i needed to
become a man and to do something good
with my life
when you [__] sit somewhere
and you think you're gonna be in there
for [__] seven months
and you don't think about escaping or
doing anything like that you're on the
right track you're saying to yourself
i'm accepting what's gonna happen to me
i'm accepting my karma i'm excited i'm
accepting my fate
and now i can move forward that this is
out of the [__] way you know it's
like how i feel now
for the last couple months i had bad
anxiety i was getting you know
i wasn't well i was struggling as a
human being you know
but i knew that the more i stuck with it
i'd get better at it you know listen
like as cliche and as [__] as this
sounds it's very true
tough times don't last tough people do
you have to look at something and go you
know what this is where i am today
in three weeks i won't be in this place
and this is what happened here you know
i i went to better help i i
i started identifying my [__]
triggers i started seeing
what people's uh
you know what my expectations were i'm
sick of repeating this
and what people's expectations were i
couldn't worry about what their
expectations were that's their
expectations they have to deal with it i
don't give a [__] about that and it's
made my life a lot better you know
for a long time i was struggling here
trying to beat myself up why i'm not
doing this why i'm not doing that you
know why because i don't want to [__]
do it
that's the [__] answer to you i don't
want to [__] do it i don't want to be
involved in that and that's just the way
it is
you know when i said goodbye to when i
left hollywood i didn't know that i was
saying goodbye to hollywood i didn't
know i had no [__] idea i don't mind
doing a couple [__] weeks in new york
like
acting i don't mind doing some simple
acting i don't want to get involved in
10 days or anything like that one two
days on a project i'm [__] in that's
the most i can handle right now at least
i'm being honest with you that's the
most i can handle anything after that
i'll start to get nervous i was talking
to a good buddy of mine
uh yesterday and we were talking he he
called me friday night he was going to
dinner at one of uh the places that i
usually go to up north he was going to
rudy's
and
he said that you know he's a mailman
he's uh 10 months from retiring
nine months from retiring he can't
[__] wait we've been friends since he
was
12 years old
14 years old i mean i moved in with the
runnies
when i was 16 17 and he was maybe 14 12
13 but i knew his brothers
i knew a bunch of kids and he was
telling me yesterday he goes you know i
didn't know
uh he was telling me friday that he went
out to dinner friday night and this
place is great it's one of the best
places i go to
the the restaurant part is is great
because it's empty
when you walk in the bar you just walk
into a den of coven
i mean
when you open the bar you're like
if these [__] don't have covert
nobody does you know i love rudy's they
got closed down because they had a covet
case uh
maybe january or february everybody had
a close down at least once it doesn't
reflect on who they are or if they're
clean or not you know it was just
covered it was [__] people up
but you know that bar gets packed in
there and people don't give a [__] i was
in there one night eating dinner when i
walked out
some guy said to me i got to go home
because my kids got covered then what
the [__] are you doing here at the bar
breathing and [__]
but that's the way it is in there if you
go in there but he was telling me he
goes you know i've been playing it great
as a post as a mailman
he goes i've been doing all this [__]
and when i walked into rudy's one of the
guys pulled me aside and was talking to
me for 10 minutes while i waited to get
my table and he goes right now i'm
sweating that i got [__] covered you
know because i was talking to him i was
thinking about that i worked so hard
this whole 18 months not to get sick
because he's he's real tight with his
mother he sees his mother his mother's
like 90.
and he goes right now i'm blowing it
because i'm talking to this [__] guy
in a restaurant and i know the guy he
was talking to a good guy
just they're all [__] drunks the
whole family great you know who gives a
[__] my point is that
you know i've been trying really hard
not to get sick
i don't want to get sick i know i got a
lot of underlying problems you know what
i'm saying but on the bright side
the doctor called me [__] thursday
when i was at the pool
to [__] my day up he's like mr diaz yes
he goes this is dr zuckerman i'm giving
you a call because i want you to come in
to talk about your heart monitor
tomorrow
i'm like tomorrow the appointment was
supposed to be on the 25th
he goes yeah i got a couple
cancellations if you want to come in
tomorrow as soon as i hung up with that
[__] i wanted to [__]
you know
why is he calling me they're gonna have
to put a stent in my heart
i'm gonna die they're gonna have to put
a [__] box whatever you call it
a pacemaker i'm not gonna get hard-ons
no more i mean i was panicking
i walked in there yesterday and the
motherfucker's like you're fine
we put the model on you for ten days
it looks like your [__] heartbeat
disappeared like that extra third beat
disappeared
so come back and see me in six months
and keep living your life
i was like are you serious he goes you
got the heart of a [__] bull
he goes the last three [__] uh
the hard things that they do when you
[__] when they put all the electrodes
on you he goes the ekgs have been
stronger
than the first one he goes i don't know
what to tell you so
i'm feeling better
better help worked you know what i'm
saying
uh i helped and uh just me doing this
and pushing through
and you guys give me the opportunity to
come into your [__] living rooms or
through your [__] car speakers
twice a week has been great i know that
i was damaged goods
for a while and you guys didn't turn
your back on me whether it was on
patreon on the joint so i owe you my
[__] life that's why i come here
every week and pour my heart out to you
[__] i don't give a [__]
because if if my [__] mistakes can
make you stronger
that's what i want that's the purpose of
me doing this i'm 58 years old i'm a i'm
an old dog who's made a lot of [__]
mistakes you can see all the mistakes
when you look at my eyes when you look
at my [__] face you could see the
mistakes i made i'm not ashamed of them
because at the end
i got what i wanted i got to come back
to jersey i got a great family i got a
great friends i got mike
you know and we're trying to do the best
podcast that we can man so
i appreciate you guys having my back i
appreciate you having on patreon i will
not ask you to [__] come see me watch
any [__] shows cause i got none you
know this is as safe as we could have it
we do our own zoom i do a zoom on
wednesdays with a guest
and i do this one for you on mondays
just to let you know what's going on in
my heart
and my head i appreciate
that you [__] guys watch today it's
monday it's a beautiful day to be alive
and this sets the tone for the [__]
week you understand me so if you think
you were having a [__] bad week i
hope now you feel better after you sat
with me and we talked about roseanne dax
shepard and the rest everybody else
who's [__] out of their [__] minds
anymore i love you [__] have a
great [__] day have a great tuesday
and i'll be back wednesday morning
tip top [__] magoo
to serve you [__] i love you
[__]
that's it and now for a word for my
[__] sponsors later
all right you bad [__] thank
you very much for watching today
we made some good points who the [__]
knows what they were i have no idea what
i talked about but i'm happy you
listened i'm happy you watched
real quick before we leave the joint is
brought to you by draftkings i [__]
love it
pacquiao and you guys hits las vegas
this weekend saturday the 21st
draftking sports book
excuse me has a tremendous [__] deal
for you they're offering 101 odds
on any punch being landed at any point
in the fight
you [__] 100 bucks who's better than
uncle joey showing up 100 worth of
credits on a [__] monday just pick a
fighter to win and draftking sportsbook
will give you 100 to one odds
bet one dollar on either fighter when a
punch lands during the fight and you'll
get a hundred dollars in free credits
who's taking care of you like that and
on the football side because football is
right around the corner also
whether you bet college or pro bet one
dollar
they're gonna give you 200
to bet the rest of the year that's
football okay that's football which
starts next week and the week after that
but pre-season is here so if you get
started with preseason just better
dollar and they'll give you 200 in
[__] credits download the top-rated
draftking sports book app not the
fantasy app the sports book app don't be
an idiot like your uncle joey i
downloaded the fantasy app but i ended
up winning so who the [__] knows take
your chances draftkings will always make
you a contender use promo code joey when
you sign up to turn a dollar into a
hundred dollars this weekend if a punch
is landed during the fight
don't pull your punches place your bets
and watch the [__] fist fly that's
code joey to turn a dollar into a
hundred dollar free credits and listen
to me draftkings doesn't stop there they
have a tremendous casino
you could still bet baseball they had
the olympics they got soccer listen if
you could bet it draftkings has it and
they've always got something for you
so this weekend it's a dollar to win a
hundred on the pacquiao ugass fight
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details new jersey
indiana or pennsylvania only you got a
gambling problem
call 1-800 gambler take care of it if
you're in indiana call 1-809 with it but
if you're ready to win some [__]
money and bit-slap some [__]
download the draftking sportsbook app
it's time to win some guinness [__]
the joint is also brought to you by
better help
what's standing in the way of you
achieving your goals
figure it out with better help i was
struggling i contacted betterhelp online
and dana [__] has helped me
tremendously she's given me coping
skills
to help with my with my anxiety and here
we are today better help is therapy for
the 21st century this is not a crisis
line this is this is not self-help
better help is professional therapy all
online and it's all remote from the
courtesy of your office or your own home
you won't have to lie on a stupid couch
and you know no it's a flexible schedule
you could do it on the phone or video
calls like i do
you get a good match they'll put you
together with a licensed therapist who
is perfect for you that's the most
important part of therapy you need
someone you feel like you could talk to
who gets you
it's fast when you sign up you can start
talking to your therapist in less than
48 hours there's no waiting around it's
affordable you don't have to have
be a fancy ass new yorker or some
[__] tutsu
and financial aid is available
and you can send messages to your
therapist anytime and they'll get back
to you in between sessions you don't
like your person if you want to switch
therapists don't do it anytime for free
they make it nice and easy
i love better help they have got me to
this place i never thought therapy would
help me but it did and i'm grateful
better help is 100 remote and available
you're ready for this worldwide
just like manscape you don't have to
live in a big city to get quality
therapy anymore trust me it helps to
save
to have someone outside your world to
talk to it's easy to schedule affordable
and they'll take a load off your
shoulders like it did for me over 1
million people have taken charge of
their mental health especially after the
pandemic join them do me a favor
go to betterhelp.com they got a special
offer to get you started visit
betterhelp.com diaz
for 10 off your first month that's 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p dot com slash diaz d-i-a-z
for 10 off your first month
betterhelp.com
diaz get better help and start living a
happier life if you you guys could tell
i'm a lot happier than i was a couple
months ago i'm not as confused the words
are coming out
betterhelp.com
diaz
if you want to ask for dana she's
tremendous the joint is also brought to
you by
manscape listen to me
you don't want to have covered and be in
the hospital with [__] a bush between
your legs
no underwear on people see your ass when
you bend over in that robe
listen it's not fun having an afro
over your dick that's why i love
manscape they don't [__] around their
advanced skin safe technology features a
ceramic blade to reduce
grooming accidents plus
the lawnmower 4.0 has a 7000
rpm motor and a travel lock it's even
waterproof
so you could [__] shave you could
trim your balls in the shower the new
lawnmower also has an led light if
you're into darkness you want to shave
in the dark [__] it i don't give a [__]
so lawnmower can help you achieve your
goals light up the dark side of your
nutsack get all that more when you order
the performance package
it includes the weed whacker for nose
and ear hair trim the weed whack is also
waterproof and uses the same skin safe
technology that you trust on your balls
and when you get the performance package
manscape will send you off with the crop
preserver a bald deodorant that's
[__] tremendous and a crop reviver to
make your balls nice and smooth they
won't look like a [__] fat guy's neck
anymore but wait there's more manscape
will throw in two free gifts the
manscape boxes that are tremendous and
the shed travel bag the performance
package 4.0 is now global it's worldwide
you can get it in [__] except cuba i
don't think they have manscaped
australia europe south africa
singapore sling who's better than you
you cannot find a better [__] deal in
the galaxy so do me a favor get 20 off
and free shipping at manscape.com
joey again that's manscape.com
joey 20 off and free shipping your balls
are going to thank you i want to thank
manscape i want to thank better help and
i want to thank draftkings for having
our back
and having your back they're also taking
care of you [__] i love you guys
with all my heart have a great monday
and i'll be back wednesday tip top magoo
ready to go i love you [__] stay
black
[Music]
you